hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play
dishonored okay we are going to the no
that's alright we're going to the golden
cat because we need to go check up on
some gimmick I'm trying to not be a
murdering bastard in this playthrough
because apparently it gives a good
ending or a bad ending if you do so
oh he's taking a leak everyone need ugh
yes so much
you heard me piss so much I whatever
gone to the Golden Calf not going up
there please thank you it's kind of
broad daylight so it's hard oh yeah so
also I need to like hang on I gotta
figure out who are you do I need to
murder you I need to figure out the old
way job oh boy how do I go to the
upgrade menu I'm actually kind of
curious about that jaw until again don't
sit here going totally forgotten how to
get to it okay man or maybe here we're
not even here I don't know I don't know
who knew how do I use my runes I
whatever you do Boosh
how are you you're just the man I was
looking for okay slack jaws wanting to
talk to oh really
I guess I'll go talk to him then ah no I
didn't mean to I'm sorry what the hell
was that
hahaha what oh man he breathed fire is
that even legal
I mean okay well we wouldn't be a
playthrough mine if I didn't die in the
first part I was an accident
accidentally hit control hello everybody
and welcome Erika blah blah blah
first I need to discover how to do hi on
I need to discover how to access this
thing so let me look at the controls cuz
I'm a ninja man dude did you do doo doo
doo doo Journal notes powers menu oh I
don't have a button assigned to the
powers menu I'm gonna make that f3 go
charge F for inventory I why is this all
not bound no it's N did I unbind
anything else I don't think so
let me jeez come on alright so every
alright so f3 oh wait no okay I get it
haha I cost three runes I have three
runes I could get any of these bend time
agility mm-hmm I'm getting - maniacal in
this and some of these are really cool
but I think I'm Andy agility one is cool
- would oh I kind of want blink but
someone said I need to get agility I
need to find more runes that's what I
need to do I need to actually hunt down
these runes so I can get better I'm
gonna blink first but I am going to use
the heart vinegar to go find more runes
oh did I get all the rooms here I
suppose I did
alright whatever then
that's that guy don't mess with me
I'm a shadow in the day not as effective
as a shadow in the night would add his
far oh no one's harder and let me quick
save with f5 yeah let Bosh hi
you're just a man I looking for I've
looking for sounds good to me just don't
breathe fire on me again cuz that was
kind of weird just just being honest
that that was strange
uh-huh I might wait am i following you
okay let's go talk to this so-called
yeah bombs the one hey I am nice facet
for you from slackjaw
okay you want to talk at the distillery
you mean this distillery the one right
here where we are at yeah let's go aim
the heart at a person to hear its
secrets
oh I don't think people people might not
be weirded out this is a strong training
me
uh-huh still remember us did you did
your your heart though how did you drink
okay whatever
is there a rune around here that I need
I need more rooms I didn't realize how
many runes I would need okay whatever
there's a bone thing over there you
black job' wait slack Bobby wait I'll
come in I gotta find something that you
would burn in the whale just need a bit
ain't you heard slack jaw keeps the good
stuff for himself three parts watered
down with water okay here we go for mr.
slack jaw whatever he wants you nah
don't care I thought I was supposed to
hear from mmm hey come here my men were
right hey no oh that's not me I'm a nice
way I figure it nice guy nobody worth
killing around here except those two
Pendleton's over in the golden cat ah
huh I'm right and I yep see slat your
nose that's what I'm gonna kill wings
rich mean and weird huh worse than most
of their it sounds good to me they've
been laying low there awhile not sure
why there's a lot of security at the
golden cat tonight though uh-huh special
guests in the like doesn't really matter
to me walk in there dress
like that and kill the Pendleton
brothers yes maybe I got a better way to
take care of them too if you're doing
something for me first understand
probably not someone I don't know who is
killing my men taking my territory
easily my good might be a fellow named
of Galvani hmm I said my best man to
investigate but he went missing in maan
well now I need someone to find what
happened to him
well then he wasn't your best man was he
he lives nearby of clattering Boulevard
okey-dokey
you do that for me and I'll get you a
better way into the golden cat I don't
need a better way into the corner yeah I
am I'm all right I'm I'm not so good at
this sneaky I'm not so good at this
sneaky but I am good at this stabby stab
gimme oh that's mine
iced tea anything else is mine oh oh
that's my - lets give me oh that's just
my fee for whatever you're having me do
for you I seriously cannot get over how
great the detail is in this game it's
just a phenomenal everything about it I
am absolutely in love with ya like about
book
bottle bread okay where's my heart gimme
heart I can't get it the bone charm over
there because it's blocked behind a wall
maybe he'll give me a key if I do what
he would he asked me to do I don't think
there's a way up above it so I guess I'm
on my own
off we go into the distance into the
unknown and here we go flew let's go out
to bottle Street again because I know
there aren't any more ruins there but I
guess the bone charms are nice too also
the loading times are deliciously low
whole town's gone the trash okay
dr. Galvani what oh hello oh that's um
it's um
James chapter the gun oh hello ah hey
don't even try man leave me doc what
what huh what oh hello what's going on
I'm so confused
hey you leave him alone oh I shouldn't
oh yeah right do this sleep up hmm give
that little I loot all this stuff here
ah oh my get off me come off me geez
freaking weirdo go to sleep that's it
bleed out I'd really like to you know
kill these people
that'd be lovely but I suppose I can't
do that if I want the good ending or
whatever let's see can you come on I
didn't upgrade this for that okay here
we go
yeah and man reach all Gary oh god I
noticed
I love you so much I just got to get in
there I'm so super stealth yak
any day the week lack boughs come on
woohoo some guy just stand-in there oh
he doesn't aw I can't kill I want to
kill people so badly I didn't want to
dab them in their faces I wanna stab
them Oh
- if they deserve to die oh but I can't
let me take your stuff and then let me
hurt and now you're sleeping good good
take the rest of your stuff
bloop go to dr. Galvani's offices sounds
good to me
combat doesn't have to end in a
bloodbath blah blah blah blah hello give
me what I eat your bread excuse me when
I walk through your stuff stealing all
your things you can go up later and take
a look after the mother - oh God okay I
guess I don't need to kill them there's
a safe over here that I want huh No
oh you don't see me I'm behind a chair
chair protect me chair yeah really
oh man
Oh God hiss laughs Oh
works I can't believe that worked take
your stuff huh yeah we'll have to carry
put you in the fireplace no one will
suspect you there oh god it's so bad I'm
getting better guys I'm getting better
no no oh don't do COO beer dugu beer oh
crap that's just ridiculous
stupid rats I leg lick sir but - crap
bunch of crap a bunch of crap that
you're gonna don't tell me you're about
to start peeing right there okay you're
talking carry your body actually this is
good place today I mean it's not a good
hiding place but whatever who's in here
anybody good oh this is a door oh I
could have gone a rent no I couldn't
have never mind never mind I thought I
could might have gone around but nope
yes let's see here some sort of privacy
screen for whenever the lady's on in
here
what sort of lady would have a bustah
that guy yeah all right
now I'm in dr. Galvani's office I'm
guessing that's dr. Galvani I just need
to find where he is clavering building
slack jaws informant he's upstairs
hey rats yeah I hear rats all right
let's just bugger upstairs and then be
on our way Oh stealthy like like shadow
in a building I see ooh miss Tony
Foreman I think he's right no come on I
mean do we have suspects suspects what
saspa how do I get around with these
people what definitely I did it a drink
but what are you gonna put on your
report I'm gonna say we found one a
slack jazz men inside all dead huh and
that you are a stinking idiot oh oh oh
oh oh they're coming they're coming
ah yes separate my little pretties go
off in different directions because you
are going to get a sleeping bolt oh no
you didn't hear a thing buddy you didn't
hear a ding dong damn thing and take
your stuff oops I say it's no good
no oh come on I'm fine go sleep what da
hell how did I set him on fire I didn't
I didn't mean you I didn't how did I
what I didn't oh crap ah sorry about
yeah sorry about that
didn't mean to kill you like that um I
meant I tried to do as much as I could
uh yeah um my bad my bad yo that's it
that's my bad I'll take responsibility
for that one okay
all right bull rat fetus say what say
what ooh
ah that's terrible
okay anyway I got I got the last message
of the guy of the informants so
hopefully I can get out of here and give
this back to the guy there and I guess
it's doesn't matter now so I can just
kind of chow is anything else of value
in here whoa what is this
hello hello okay just a back door into
that area all right so we're good are we
good
rat mm right that's a jowl hmm like a
shadow down the stairs was that
clavering doom Boulevard touch how give
you that and I don't think I ever found
the combination to this noob
oh no okay all right that's a shame but
whatever I don't have time to just
wander around in the streets I have a
schedule to keep
oh I love those quick low tax lovin
lovin level poop
back to blink thank you thank you
running around on the roof no no see me
no one will suspect you okay um oh and
then who I'm up here not bad
Boop more goodies I love me some goodies
I know about the spring razor thank you
very much copper wire I don't know what
that's for
see here OOP flat out give me that bone
charm
hey cool I didn't even need the heart
good and in here bloop
done and done like a Bose alright so I'm
trying to get back down as I need to get
down there okay recharge me and I'm
surprised you didn't look surprised at
all oh yeah now you do delayed reaction
man going into the dunwall distillery
thank you hey hey wait a minute nope
what just occurred cuz you're a loser
alright let me get back here and did
y'all Oh triple kill scuse me pardon me
need to talk to your boss don't mind me
that I have my sword out if you know
what I mean yeah
by the way I am playing naked again just
because I can and because you all can't
see I'm actually standing up now yeah
now I'm putting on a little dance can't
you tell slack jump high where's slack
oh why is he out there cow come on
Brandon all the way here you all
probably saw that a long time ago never
mind
I'm an idiot yeah okay hello here's
Crowley's last words of course here
what's these uh-huh information from my
missing guy yes let's have a listen let
us do
like Jo will be proud you're making this
occasion I'll make it back it was right
there is someone what you did
uh-huh what to take over the dishes
Hillary the whole bottle street game
you'll never believe what is go tell us
first acted that's why it taking me so
well say the name I wanted to be sure no
too bad you didn't say who is worth of
course still you and me had a deal and I
thought Joe never goes back on a deal
right take this key it ain't for the
golden cart no mmm is keys for the
captain's chair your hotel abandoned
since the plague gutted this part of
town cool take the stairs to the top you
can use the move to get into the Golden
Calf brother hey not bad
see that select row keeps a bargain
uh-huh just as good as the men who run
the city right maybe a little better you
think about that okey-dokey now maybe we
can help each other out again maybe I
could get rid of the Pendleton's for you
no no I
without killing them I'm gonna murder
them but you got to do something from me
in return if I can't murder normal
guards I'm going to kill the targets
let's see I don't mind getting my hands
dirty
alright then just come back if you
change your mind absolutely cuz I mean
I'm not a I'm not a psychopath but I
gotta get my murder on I mean come on he
got to unleash the beast every once in a
while if you know what I mean anyway doo
doo doo just going off at my blade is
already covered in blood
don't worry I won't set any gourds on
fire I'm just gonna go kill these guys
yes
come on oh come on tell me I can't climb
up there someone's still prowling around
you mean me
um I guess if I go there group up here
again damn it Burt leo and then let's
see here where am I going actually
golden cat I'm going over there alright
fine by me Boop you could do no
inspecting I'm a shadow on the pipes
hello a mandatory whale oil ration is
now in effect do don't wait long
punishable offense mm-hmm damn it
alright so I'm getting through there I
gotta get up
Booton no one saw anything do you know
what did I know that
a rattler what uh
it's one of Sokka love's latest
invention crap
they say the idea came yes yes know how
it works I really couldn't say but all
the hairs on your body stand up when you
walk through it keep your men in ten
okay also kills you I need to get rid of
these whale oil tanks
freaking whale how is whale oil look no
oh come on
uh-uh you didn't see you think oh I knew
that was good oh okay anyway so trying
again whale oil red wait Lloyd a rashing
today all that it's got to be a way
around a little bit
probably down that way and let me check
that Boop
it's all things oh ow well this doesn't
seem to be helping at all it's almost by
me no no no we did something I thought
he's so filthy mudlark very [ __ ] like
you get elixir we've been on I read I
got you the plague ah no you leave it
alone what's that you're asleep nope
nope nope nope no room thank you sir
you're welcome baby saved me yeah
oh I could think of a few ways yeah wait
take this okay
it's the back door service key to
buntings house is that it deals on the
Main Street
ob I used to work for him either oh come
on before the plague all right he'd let
all his servants go but he's still there
uh-huh probably hoping he'll be able to
sell something from that safe of his
mm-hmm
I don't know what he has left oh we have
to offer you oh okay
long oh well alright so much for being
the hero I guess I'm too heartbroken
over the loss of my whatever name was
the Empress of whatever is this come on
let me get up there let me get up there
let me get up there
let me get up I mean oh I remember this
place
Damon how am I gonna get in there though
let's see here quick say I need to get
down there or there's a guy patrolling
right there and I really control there's
a stand there I'll go around good like a
shadow in the Sun no one's I bang go Moo
g'day if you don't know when there's
from go watch 5 second films they're
phenomenal I absolutely love 5 second
films and that's one of my favorites
I think it's called about to blow or
something just just watch it is
hilarious bone charm yeah I don't know
what these bone charms do but I'll find
out is not a bottle bone charm bullet
I'm full of bullets robust hell yeah
Acrobat hell yeah mmm
i likey marki likey
all right like shadow in the night again
blah blah blah rats Wow ah no no don't
kill me I wasn't scared I wasn't scared
at all if you think I was scared you
were wrong you're dead wrong
uh-uh I'm never I am never scared like a
shadow in a stairwell hey cha ho okay
going day oh ha ha yeah I think I'm
gonna like this place let me just create
a save here ha ha ha ha
yeah the upcoming area is riddled with
pathways that allow many approaches to
accomplish your mission look for
overhead ledges rat tunnels water
passages and hiding places you've got it
oh this oh wait what this is far away
nice place though really nice I love the
architecture uh you know it must be fun
just to be a map designer and just be
able to create a city like this I mean
there's something that I wanted to do a
while ago it may be something that I
dabble in again because I mean it's just
really really really cool I mean the
sort of stuff they do I see ruin and
bone charm nearby I'm not kidding roon
roon roon ok these rooms where that room
it's already a lady on on duty I'm on
duty and I make time for you baby on ik
time all the time in the world for you
oh me too baby me too okay all right
there we go little drop down here it was
our thing like a shadow on a heating
vent I mean yes yeah
gosh too powerful yes okay now get the
other rooms as well up there you say
well that sure is easy for me to get
roof Oh put the big rats ticket stripper
corpse that nothing in seconds uh-huh
that's from the continent I got a cousin
sick oh come on let me let me climb up
there what I wanna climb even if you're
right fine what do we do then don't get
back up there the whole country
comforter I don't get my good there I
want to get back up maybe bigger oh yeah
yeah good thing I upgraded blink cheese
all right quick save lack back okay I
just got to get in that second-floor
window you don't see anything buddy you
don't see you think they're both it is
on the first need to get the men in
position hello we're all the ladies at
oh all right let's get the rune and
about no let's get the room the bomb
turns farther away than I thought it was
actually first let me make sure no
oh hello baby you ain't gonna make a
racket for me are ya
or maybe you are hey hey you're actually
in the same room as that what's up
you're just gonna gonna get it now
notice me
give me pardon me follow me baby excuse
me
oh you so fine sorry but I don't have
time for that baby I gotta go off and do
my own thing okay
Maroons yes all right what can I get
bend time shadow kill we'll see someone
said to get agility next so I think I'm
gonna do that point yeah held to the
yeah Oh bah baby I barely knew don't
look at me okay so that other room is
downstairs and my goal is actually the
Madam's office uh oh I guess I could I
guess I could pay her a visit
yeah
all but the runes over there have the
runes on the other side I might as well
be over here for now who's that oh
that's the sideways painting or a second
there I thought it looked like garish
from now that's completely wrong it was
actually a lady hello baby
you wanna have a little chitchat steel
Oh like a shadow and steel Oh Oh steel
and steel that you you didn't see
anything lighting door move my damn leg
in the night I now let me just get a
scouting report of where the people as
and they're not even gonna be in even us
what no oh come on you didn't see
anything man
so let's see is there another window I
get in probably give me on me no one saw
a thing guys there whew
that with Pelton's are one of them
anyway it looks like now how do I get in
how do I use that to my advantage where
the balderdash hey wait this looks
familiar
this looks like a scene from a trailer
of some sort
it's gotta be a way to get in from the
side or something I know it's like I
just got to go in through the top I will
sneak in like a shadow on a Ledge that's
not right no no you don't see it you
really use it no you didn't see anything
one of why there are so many guards in
here anyway is it just because the pedal
tens are here or is like oh this is
normal guard for I'm gonna I'm going to
incapacitate this gentleman good no
that's alright who come to remember blah
thank you
excuse me right behind this little
privacy screen
he's just sitting down for a little nap
all right now yes two guys over there
some lady on a couch that nice girl
again uh-huh I told you you realize
you're at the golden cat right no no
yeah but she's different
no yeah like a [ __ ] she does idiot she
likes your money not you you're just
jealous
who would like you anyway you have you
you over here but oh you know oh come on
what the hell
Oh Oh God it was bull crap got you now
no you dog that was bulk that was such
bull crap that was such bull crap that
was just a bunch of ma come on nope you
didn't get anything
Josie's door behind me I'm trying to be
generous and not kill people
oh is it bad light that's a good place
to be hello in there oh come on baby
alone going oh that's um
alright fine you know what
nope okay thank you
golly are these people are sleeping okay
even well I just pick that I can't take
carry any more remedies I need a more
renomii
Bremen REM rent remedy I need another
remedy because I'm almost out of hello
oh there it is
why was that just a pair evening well I
just refresh my ah come on don't be like
this fine this guy's gonna die oh the
gum
damn it all right I can't get over my
murdering instinct is just too strong
okay so that's it right
that's all I just booted that body out
in there okay that's it right nobody
else gonna come to the party
right right right okay Hey Oh
mm I don't know you get a good look
say what he wanted I know you say a word
but he went through the place like the
outsider himself okay blanks driven
crazy he didn't fight plate eyes there
there I need to go to that one guys in
the ivory room one guys in the smoky
right here dammit I'm using up all my
man I'm trying to get this done what you
didn't see anything around no I will not
that's not my target is it huh no no no
so this guy just gets sleep clip bourbon
now place this guy inconspicuously over
a crap nikka thank you is leave right
there Oh stupid cut Oh anyone you want
the high overseer for all I care I've
never been this drunk no some of my
friends say look like lady Boyle who's
that Waverly
lucky trollop I found those crystal
deposits on my estate car throwing
parties to I'd be buying the Lord
region's favorite too instead of begging
for money right they mean to upset you
my lord
wait mm-hmm wait he be taking father
maybe you should dress up like her what
a weirdo I should like to teach her a
lesson I know how do I kill him without
getting really like mean white or black
oh I get it
let me think about this Waverly ditto is
like black mm-hmm oh is that Lydia mmm
okay she's gonna go change and I'm gonna
go in for the kill crap no you didn't
see a thing lady of course you didn't
why would you know stop looking over
here no hmm stop your people are weird
stop walking around the room as if you
okay
so he's looking over there that guy's
looking straight over here but I can get
in for that
no nope okay um lady you're gonna just
hold on
zip it come on oh crap I've screwed this
up fast just kill me just kill me kill
me okay all right black
all right so hmm how do I get her out of
the picture if I had a sleeping Dart
I would just do that ah her single word
but he went through the place like the
outsider himself the blanks giving him
crazy let's see it here I play see this
guy's a problem I'm gonna take care of
this guy and then I gotta take care of
the other guy outside the other the
other entrance first okay soon as this
guy moves here goes okay in for the
sneaky sneak kami Lulu guy I got your
[ __ ] and you come with me and I'll put
you right here
let's tic-tac can't carry any more ammo
of that tape I go out here and there's a
guy on the balcony then I can take I
know there was a way inside
come on I can't quite reach it there we
go there we are just like that
know that guys whoops oh that's how you
oh that's how you put away your weapon
you hold em don't fall off man don't
roll off I don't want you to die mmm now
how do I get in here yes I think I
should like to teach her a lesson I
would be glad to my lord when you like
me in white or black all right let me
think about this
Waverly did always like black what was
that Lydia how do I get her out of the
picture without killing her you're just
gonna stand there like a creep and not
do anything aren't you aren't you cuz
you're a weirdo big big weirdo I just
gotta get her out of the picture maybe
oh I see I see an opportunity maybe if I
just choke hold her
and then I can yes yes yes stay no you
didn't see a thing
yes it wasn't elegant but it worked it
was brilliant
again she's unconscious and no one's
coming in yes persuade the art dealer it
is uh-huh okay alright whatever I don't
know what that was all about but either
way I got it done
I mean I imagine that this game has a
lot of other stuff
I mean don't take it the wrong way if
you if you see me playing through this
game there are so many other ways that
you can play through this game I
encourage everyone watching to buy this
game oh come on fine
oh oh that was about to kill me that was
supposed to murder me dead uh-huh but
seriously this game is actually an
incredible game and if I wasn't doing a
let's play I would take much more time
and effort to make sure that everything
I do is very pristine I'm just trying to
make it fun at the moment come on that
was supposed to kill off quick load
there we go much better
Oh give me your corner you gotta be
kidding me oh god I thought I saved
after this already let me think about
this
mmm-hmm Waverly did always like black no
I didn't wait for sleep yeah you got to
turn around again
damnit oh damn it damn it damn it damn
it damn it damn it damn it damn it damn
it damn it damn it
OOP what the hell
Oh what that was awesome
where did the lady go her body just like
vanished not sure but either way that
was awesome
ha ha have cigarettes all right now
that's taken care of doesn't look like
anyone else was alerted so quick saved
and here we go Wow no I just I just
healed why did I take another one all
right so I need to get down to the ivory
room now I'm assuming there's gonna be a
way to drop down over here hmm I hope I
didn't like somehow kill that lady I
don't think I did
oh maybe not hmm
oh I guess all right I guess I'll just
go down the long way
in fact you so didn't see anything that
you're not gonna notice this you
probably rats yeah probably
hello sorry ladies excuse me you didn't
see anything you guys are so stupid you
guys are so stupid
you don't even know what there's a
sneaky going on no no no you're smart
you're smart you're smart man so don't
come over here or else you will die you
can either live a dumb man or styie
start man good that's what I thought
now I dare you to stay over there those
two ladies are so preoccupied nope fur
city urban herbs oh oh oh I could have
just dropped down here okay whoops Mabi
OOP hurt and you're good just wait yard
yeah hey mmm snoring like a baby now 41
against us but the bylaws stay
region's provisional bylaws uh-huh
that's exactly right
ah they state that the conservative
position gets an extra three votes right
in the month of timber is that true
how on earth do you know that oh she's
so smart a courtesan Lord Pendleton I
was a clerk to Lord Esther mom uh-huh
what happened to old ass tomorrow I
don't know
dead Oh an old sewer line led under his
office in Parliament and they all came
rushing out mmm they say the other lords
barricaded him in to save themselves
right
the screams lasted hours he begged and
called them by name but they let him die
that sucks
I would have murdered all the rats
anyway now she's gonna be a problem
again I don't I don't have any sleeping
darts lucky bastard otters and extra
nicely candy bed yeah I know it's a
shame
how do I get I gotta I need like a
bottle or something as a distraction is
there a bottle over here that I could
use I just need to get them apart
nothing I can't even pick up these
chairs bollocks
whoo whoo whoo whoo whoo whoo whoo don't
come in here there's dead bodies you
don't want to be out here man you do not
want to be up here exactly
you stay on your own and I'll stay on my
own what does that mean
space what I just like bust through the
window right this would I curious
nope okay no so stop they're just gonna
stand there like douches
alright I'm gonna try something here new
oh crap Oh learn murder and now you are
going to be put to sleep just for a
little bit in flip just like that
like a mouse yes yes and that's actual
perfect timing because I have just run
out of time thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done licks it and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye